the attitude before was like oh you know
these are consenting adults they can do
whatever they want whatever but you're
realizing a lot of these people have a
parasocial relationship they really want
to be with these people that's why
they're that's why the number one thing
on only fans is not the videos or the
content it's actually the messaging
they're talking they're talking to these
women and you're not even talking to her
you're talking to her assistant or some
right just to feel a connection with
somebody whoa I even spent an additional
30,000 more on you since we met because
I thought we had something genuine and
real that's 90,000 godam I will empty my
bank account just to be with you I will
travel across the country just to
randomly run into you again stop saying
randomly that's not randomly I don't
think you know what randomly means this
one comes straight from Ruby Rose what
going on she ended up meeting one of her
best fans from her only fans cool cuz
it's her and her fan they do a little
photo op she's very happy that's Ruby
Rose yep that's a Ruby Rose we know yep
Whiz Khalifa Ruby Rose no you're
thinking about the Baldhead Amber Rose
Amber Rose my bad Ruby Rose is a rapper
oh my bad who also has my fault my fault
I did not we don't want them rappers be
like Oh My py My Booty hold yeah yeah
yeah I bleach it every day cuz I got to
so this is the fan right here that
coochie up that coochie
bre That Coochie bre spread them B ass
over let that coochie breathe put me to
bed call me Lord not let it breathe I
don't be George
Floyd all right all
right okay anyways so and the reason why
this went vient blew up in one month
look how much he
donated uh it is
633215 in one month this Man
donated your salary does he have the
money for it uh he calls himself a
crypto whale looking for a queen
it's none of my business I don't that is
wild
$63,000 donation is W you only been so
for a month let me ask you another
question go ahead what are the odds they
made up by
mistake he says I ran into my number one
spender ran
into number one spender in a big city
like Atlanta come on ran into he
following her he he probably been like
yo where you at baby I'm coming there or
she supposed to sing a lot of where
she's going to be at or she has a
meeting GRE and stuff like that she's a
rapper it's easy to run into her yeah
yeah so it wasn't no accidents they
didn't run into each other no he's like
where you at I'm
coming yeah oh he came already pause
someone below posted yo his meat every
day yeah people going to spend some cash
on
girls Hey listen I'm do $63 at least
need want of ass grab or something like
there's no amount of content that's
worth that much so you know you got to
be chatting you got to be you got to be
chatting they got to be typing but it's
probably not even her typing it's
probably her assistant
typing as a business like you can do
whatever he wants with money it's his
right at what point do you just get
diminishing returns though it's like you
know P like 10K like cuz you get access
to all the content for like 60 bucks a
month or whatever then you get private
chats for like a th000 no that was a 63
is like that is a corporate decision
that he made of giving that money okay
tell me there's some people that are
that feel good about giving money that's
their thing that's their way of feeling
good about themselves ha I gave look how
much I can give it feels good to give it
feels good to give but it's only feels
good to give if you get recognition for
giving in that sense not necessarily
well oh wait no that's not true wait
wait wait yes I see what you're saying
you need to be acknowledged I see what
you're saying and he's being
acknowledged he's being posted he's that
Ruby Rose Story the one with those
$63,000 yeah the update on Tuesday she
took to Twitter to share some stuff that
uh he
sent look at the bottom read what it
says at the
bottom what does it
say what does it say at the bottom read
it you you going to have to give me time
my
man
number one
spender Hey Big
Spender spend a 100,000 on me and then
she's like well here's some of the
messages the guy's been sending two days
ago why aren't you answering I thought
we had a genuine connection yesterday
Ruby why aren't you answering me I've
invested so much money into our
relationship I am in love with you
that's 3 hours later why won't you love
love me and then look this is not woody
bro I'm not going to read that it's a
lot I will read it oh my I got you yay I
got you he paid 100 grand for this
somebody better See Him and acknowledge
Him Let It Be Me pause I would do
anything for you I would fly anywhere to
be with you all that I can ever think of
is you there is not a single other
person in this world as perfect as you
are you could be my queen and I could be
your
king this makes me think of a song
you could be my everything I don't know
but we're not this is not a song No More
this is real life it's only cute in a
song most songs most R&B songs are super
creepy and then this is actually an R&B
song if you listen to R&B songs and
like that it's either creepy or like yo
that is you you should okay think
about Excuse Me Miss I saw you from
across the room it's essentially a man
who sees a woman from across the room
and follows her through an under pass
through a basketball court to her car
and then gets inside of the car with her
n it's only not creepy cuz it's Chris
Brown but all you viewers watching at
home don't try it you go to jail my
girl give the money back at this point
for your safety this man is tripping I
thought it was a relation where the guy
is like yo let me spend and this and
that that's not what it is this man
can't get it and he's is paying to get
it and he's expecting and he has way
more expectations well how do you know
you haven't even read the messages I
don't care that long of a message uh why
aren't you answering I love you we have
a relationship I don't need to read the
paragraph to know that it's um mental
health mental health oh why cuz it's a
long paragraph what if it's reasonable
what if it's like we can start with
coffee you could even keep this than you
tried though I go no go ahead go ahead
read read let's see if if it's sensible
I would give you anything you could ever
wish
for we can even have a one-sided
open-end relationship where you can do
whatever you want as long as I know at
the end of the day you come home to me
and you are only with me I promise I
will treat you better than anyone Ruby
hey yo hey the red pill about to lose it
on my boy oh yeah absolutely I love you
with all of my heart uh hold on you know
what I know how to read this now I love
you with all of my heart I've never felt
this way about anyone and I want to
marry you I want to have a family with
you I want to only be with
you I would quit everything just give up
everything just for you I love you Ruby
I only love you I will give up
everything please don't ignore me you
are on my mind every day thinking of you
smelled thinking of how you smelled in
the hotel lobby when I first saw you
thinking of your first your perfect
smile I was told I would be your number
one fan everything about you makes me
get
butterflies why are you ignoring me
after all the money that I given you to
show you that I'm only loyal to you my
guy that's what I'm saying giving
someone money does not mean that you're
loyal to them give the money back
restraining order stop this is I see you
actively posting on Instagram story and
you have not answered me once you are
making me very mad right afterwards I'm
sorry for getting mad at you I didn't
mean to I shouldn't have but the love I
have for you causes me to get very
emotional especially about you I know we
only met for 5 minutes and that you had
to leave but I had cherished it so much
you have become my sole purpose in life
baby please answer me my queen I want to
marry you I even spent an additional
30,000 more on you since we met because
I thought we had something genuine and
real that's 90,000 godam I will empty my
banking account just to be with you I
will travel across the country just to
randomly run into you again stop saying
randomly that's not randomly I don't
think you know what randomly means my
guy that's like you walking is you oh I
randomly BM into you oh what are the
odds that randomly run into the woman I
want to marry and spend the rest of my
life with and I've been sending two
messages to her and $100,000 total stop
oh my God this is so Random this is
surprise will you marry me okay calm
down Carlo malice I'm trying to channel
his energy yeah I'm sorry it was a
little aggressive yeah a bit but it's
hard for me to get into character
without doing that okay mea take me
please I will send you 10 Bitcoin right
now if you answer me that is worth
almost
$400,000 all you have to do is respond
to me with one word Ruby please I need
your attention Bitcoin is one of those
Investments I was talking to you about
on only friends when you asked me what I
did to make so much money I promise you
you would be the best investment of your
life life oh he changed it up kitten are
you there my message say you read them
but it would could be a glitch like the
last time when it said you read it for 4
days and you said you
didn't trust me the technology is not
broken it's just your brain this man
said I love you more than I love Bitcoin
uh do you have any thoughts
no okay but yesterday you knowy the
attitude before was like oh you know
these are consenting adults they can do
whatever want whatever but you're
realizing a lot of these people have a
parasocial relationship they really want
to be with these people that's why
they're that's why the number one thing
on only fans is not the videos or the
content it's actually the messaging
they're talking they're talking to these
women there's that relationship this is
like a a symptom of extreme loneliness
or obsessive Behavior that's really
disgusting I don't want to blame
loneliness for this per se no
that's not that's but you know what I'm
saying like a lot of these dudes who are
signed up for these service are
genuinely lonely whoa does that mean we
have to start feeling bad or sad for
them bot everyone's got to make their
own choices but it is I think a sad
circumstance that you got to pay some
Instagram girl who out here taking off
her clothes or whatever and you're not
even talking to her you're talking to
her assistant or some right just to
feel a connection with somebody whoa we
have become so tournament online that
people would talk to someone who's not
even that person they're talking to just
to feel a bit of a connection and
they'll drain their savings their bank
accounts for this side stuff remember
when Andrew T was talking about how he
used to talk on behalf of his girls and
he would have these people selling their
homes and he would take advantage of
them that's a reality for a lot of these
people you know there's a lot of victims
on the other ends of these kinds of
things not every one of them are victims
is what I'm trying to say
but there is a sad demographic of people
who are into this and there's
people who are profiting from
it so say what you
will
but that's sad my man put in 100K just
to get ignored and she don't have any
duty to respond to him she don't this
dude is unhinged but for her and her
safety I give the money back and listen
this is we're not doing this I wouldn't
I would not give the money back I would
use the money to get security because I
don't think giving him the money back is
going to make him go away at all in fact
if she did that he's going to get more
upset how dare you how could you this is
a gift for you he would lose it you're
not oh you give me my money back I'm
moving on there's no way all right well
that's it for today's video let us know
what you think in the comments
90,000 uh more than that close to
100 what other creature could get that
much money out of a fan in like a single
month for so little return you might go
to a club and you might see people like
spend 10 20 bands whatever fine okay
they blowing some girls back out they
going up to the VIP section and they
probably gting some po my man got a
picture my man my man got a picture of
public shout out that's wild we don't
know the
rest he probably just got a picture he
just got a picture and me it's just the
psyche of the dudes who would pay that
for that Knowing damn well a lot of
these dudes could get the highest end
escorts in their city for actual real
like oneon-one so my question is this
when you get to the level of a weirdo
like this right
what compels you to spend money on the
only fans thing like that when you could
be in public with the baddest
broad at a restaurant he don't want to
be having having oysters slurp down your
don't he don't want to be in public why
he in a picture with her in public
that's one thing that's one thing but
you don't want to necessarily like or
maybe he thinks actually yeah is that he
has maybe this fantasy about her but
that's the closest that they can get
access to her and having to talk and
having the impr
it's like you know this is the closest I
could get yeah he can get any girl he
wants her he wants her he could get any
girl any any ex- worker he could get
that he wants her he wants to talk to
her he wants to see them pictures her
it's very Niche very personal very
oneon-one yeah the closest he can get is
all this and then he ran into her we'll
see what's going to happen and maybe oh
yeah I gave you a 63 whatever that last
month how much is it going to be to have
a night with you just to to want and
dine oh it's going to be 100 B and he's
going to Fork out the money and then she
going to get that 100 B for that one
night and then he's going to try to
escalate it maybe she's going to say yes
or no it is going to be what it is going
to be we are in the era of
[Music]
Niche and people don't want anything
they want that thing I don't want to see
any pom I got the people that are using
the off and stuff like that they don't
want anything they want that one they
saw that one o I want that
butk at 63k you got you got to at least
get like a a sniff of the feet you got
to get something no a picture it's like
that's like going to Disneyland get a
picture with the mascots like yo you got
to sniff like the dinosaur butthole you
got to do something for
63k that's a lot of money you got to
hear something I'm just saying why you
trying to Dinosaur but hole in
Disneyland but if I'm paying 63k I want
the experience or something like if
somebody was I'm 100% taking that money
out of your bank account and you're
going to see this dinosaur something got
to happen something got to happen how
much did I pay for that D for me to be
able to sleep at night knowing that
money left my bank account something got
to happen I would be like how much I pay
for that
dinosaur 63k he let's make these
putting my dick in there yeah I'm
putting my dick in there we making these
extinct again listen this is a
life of some people I know the streamer
amaranth she has people send her 20
bands cash so she don't even got to
declare they're sending her ammunition
and different gifts like I don't know I
don't understand these men I don't get
why they do it I don't have to but they
exist they exist and there's women who
are profiting yep a whole leap of
them a holy bam that's life on easy mode
anything else no
let's let's he's out of it the easiest
63k I ever heard yeah that is correct
yeah